j'aurai le temps une minute de m'énerver
juste de m'énerver de paraître pour un
petit merdeux un petit jeune de [ __ ]
la pagaille parking je vous signale que
la jeunesse française se fout
strictement de ce que monsieur marché
faisait pendant la guerre ça lui est
complètement égal france et on s'en fout
il n'y a jamais eu un jeune ministre de
l'ap de la jeunesse en france il y en a
jamais eu et c'est tous des vieux
regardez monsieur soissons enfin vous
n'allez pas me dire que c'était un homme
représentatif de la jeunesse regarder
comment je suis habillé ils sont plus
souvent biais com - les jeunes que comme
monsieur soissons ce que je vous donnais
en tout cas c'est généralement c'est un
avertissement
j'ai peut-être du culot de faire ça je
suis obligé de le faire comme ça parce
que je dois faire vite ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que la jeunesse
désespère elle est profonde et
profondément désespéré parce qu'elle n'a
plus d'appuis elle ne croit plus en la
politique française et moi je pense qu
est la règle générale résume en un peu
bien raison ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que le désespoir et mobilisateur
et que lorsqu'il devient mobilisateur il
est dangereux et que ça entraîne le
terrorisme la bande à baader et des
choses comme ça et ça il faut que les
grandes personnes qui dirigent le monde
soit prévenu que les jeunes vont finir
par virer du mauvais côté parce qu'ils
n'auront plus d'autre solution